trying to avoid fallout spoilers right
now is like trying to avoid an actual
nuclear bomb strike you can hide in
volts all you like but some of that
spoiler radiation is still going to
creep in somehow and turn you into a
mutant but instead of extra arms you'll
just know more about fallout than you
wanted to I'm Kate and this is your
gamespot news update about how fallout
4s gunplay is apparently modeled after
destiny when designing fallout 4s new
shooting mechanics developers at
Bethesda Game Studios use bungees
shooter destiny considered by some to
have some of the best gun play in games
as a reference point that's according to
game informer's story on the game
published in the magazine's latest issue
but there's the developers or destiny is
a touchstone for fallout 4 shooting
mechanics because bungees game runs at
30 frames per second just like fallout 4
the main difference in the way we
develop is that we will develop with as
many knobs as possible fallout 4
director todd howard said we're always
thinking of scale we're not a team
that's just going to make eight guns and
spend forever on one gun we knew we were
going to have thousands so we needed to
develop a gun system that had all of the
dials helping develop fallout 4s gunplay
is Josh Hamrick you left Bungie after
six years to join Bethesda he works at
Bethesda as a senior systems designer
and in his new role has been focused
intently on tuning fallout falls
firearms hamrick was also part of the
team that designed fallout 4s
PlayStation Vita controls speaking about
Fallout 4 shooting mechanics in June
Howard said that they will improve upon
what was seen in fallout 3 the shooting
game in that system was very met Howard
said at the time we started out with
fallout 4 knowing that look we can't
apologize for being a role-playing game
he said we have to build a first-person
shooter and it needs to be a really
really good one we spent a lot of time
on that we want players to have the edge
if they use the VAT system Howard said
if you're building your character for
vats it's really powerful do you think
fallout is a good shooter do you care
about the shooting mechanics at all let
us know in the comments or come find me
on Twitter at how not to draw make sure
to check out gamespot com for our
extensive fallout coverage including a
very own fallout show and thanks for
watching